Traduttore: Alessandra Tadiotto
Revisore: Chiheb Larmani
Siete rilassati? Beati voi.
Non c'è da ridere.
(Ride)
Allora, come potete vedere,
la mia storia comincia da una fotografia.
Mi trovavo sul monte Brento,
vicino ad Arco,
sotto di me c'erano mille metri di vuoto,
senza scorciatoie.
Ero lì assieme a due miei carissimi amici,
Luca e Michele,
per un contest internazionale
di fotografia d'arrampicata,
che mi chiedeva di portare
quattro immagini
che poi sarebbero state valutate assieme.
Avevo da così tanto tempo in mente
una fotografia,
che delle altre tre, diciamocelo,
non mi importava poi molto,
la competizione era una cosa secondaria.
Eppure, nel momento in cui
scattai questa fotografia,
non ero per niente soddisfatto.
Forse era già anche troppo tardi,
perché il sole si era alzato
ed aveva lasciato...
cioè aveva incendiato
la parte superiore della parete
lasciando un baratro nero sotto di sé.
È stato in quel momento in cui,
forse per fortuna,
con la stessa luce
che mi accecava la vista,
vedevo una cengia un centinaio
di metri più in là, sulla mia sinistra.
Sentivo che forse valeva
la pena andar lì a vedere
come sarebbe cambiata la prospettiva.
Già mi maledivo perché non avevo portato
una corda statica in più
con la quale calarmi
in quel punto in sicurezza.
Infatti il bosco in quel punto,
sulla cima del monte Brento,
era molto ripido,
ricoperto di foglie,
a loro volta ricoperte da rugiada
della mattina stessa.
Allora camminavo facendo attenzione,
le suole consumate delle mie scarpe
mi dicevano di non fidarmi,
mi aggrappavo ai pochi rami che c'erano,
fino a quando non sono arrivato
a sbalzo sulla parete.
Ho dovuto cominciare a disarrampicare
delle rocce.
Cercavo di non tirarle,
ma di premerle verso il basso con le mani
e con i piedi
per fare in modo, appunto,
di non estrarre queste rocce
da quel tenero guscio di terra
che le custodiva.
In cinque, dieci minuti,
ero arrivato su quella cengia.
Io sono dentro quel puntino rosso
e non ho mai fatto vedere
questa fotografia a mia mamma.
Scusa.
Mi voltavo e Luca
e Michele erano ancora lì,
ad aspettare una mia indicazione.
E proprio in quel momento
è avvenuto quello che speravo.
Sulla cima del monte Brento
vedevo la sagoma di due base-jumper.
Io non sapevo chi loro fossero,
ma sapevo che forse li avrei trovati lì.
Il tempo di un salto nel vuoto
e sette frame al secondo.
Nel momento in cui ho visto
uno di quei sette frame
sullo schermo LCD della mia fotocamera,
inutile dirvi che mi sono commosso.
Mi sono sentito vivo.
Eppure un paio di ore più tardi,
mi sono reso conto che quel gesto
di prendersi quel rischio
forse era stato qualcosa
di veramente inutile.
Allo stesso tempo mi sono domandato:
È stata proprio l'inutilità di quel gesto
a rendere quel momento così importante,
così intenso.
Eppure dicono che l'inutilità
non abbia una forma, un valore,
né tanto meno un fine.
Però per me, per un secondo,
aveva significato tutto.
Guardando questa fotografia
penso che molti di voi vedano
quattro persone
in uno spazio indefinito,
quasi un'immagine vuota, no?
Eppure il giorno in cui ho scattato
questa fotografia
ci trovavamo in una tempesta di neve,
e la presenza della natura
era talmente forte
che non avvertivi un senso di mancanza,
un vuoto,
sentivi questa presenza che ti avvolgeva,
e che in un certo senso
ti riempiva l'anima.
Perché vi dico questo?
Sapete, noi esseri umani
diamo il significato a una parola
attraverso l'esperienza che ne facciamo.
Ovvero, il più delle volte,
è l'esperienza stessa il significato
che diamo a una parola.
Avete mai pensato
che significato diamo
alla parola utilità?
Sfogliando velocemente un dizionario,
scopriamo che un oggetto,
un'azione, un pensiero
viene definito utile
nel momento in cui o ha uno scopo,
o in termini economici, ha un valore.
Lì mi sono domandato:
Andare oltre l'utile,
il convenzionale, l'imposto,
è davvero così inutile come crediamo?
Oppure è proprio porre l'utilità
come scopo finale il nostro vero limite?"
C'era una persona,
c'è perché è tuttora vivo,
una persona che aveva da dire la sua
su questa cosa.
Si chiama Yvon Chouinard.
Yvon Chouinard,
per chi di voi non lo conosce,
è un alpinista, un serfer,
un imprenditore statunitense.
Yvon Chouinard in una
delle sue più famose citazioni
una volta disse: "Arrampicare
è uno sport inutile,
si diventa conquistatori dell'inutile,
in vetta ci si può arrivare in molti modi,
ma è il come ad essere importante."
Ebbene, penso che qua, nessuno di noi,
in questo bellissimo teatro,
spenderebbe il proprio tempo
per fare qualcosa di inutile,
ovvero sprecherebbe la risorsa
per definizione finita
e per noi più importante
per, forse così, sprecarla,
non darle una utilità.
Sapete, io penso che noi esseri umani,
come uomo moderno,
abbiamo due problemi principali:
il primo è che troppo, troppo spesso,
confondiamo le parole utilità e felicità.
Pensiamo che siano la stessa cosa.
Noi pensiamo che essere felici sia
fare tante cose in poco tempo
e, perché no, con un profitto.
Per me è allucinante.
Nel senso, così facendo,
qualsiasi cosa che si estrae
dalla nostra sfera lavorativa,
la definiamo di conseguenza inutile.
Il secondo problema che non so nemmeno io
se sia più o meno grave del primo
è che, così facendo, non arriviamo più
a fare quello che vogliamo,
quello che desideriamo nel profondo,
ma facciamo quello che ci conviene.
Il più delle volte, o ce ne pentiamo,
o ce ne lamentiamo.
Sapete, se vi dico questo, è perché
penso di averlo vissuto in prima persona
in uno dei momenti più importanti
nella vita di ognuno di noi,
ovvero durante l'istruzione.
Infatti io mi sono iscritto
a un liceo scientifico
perché pensavo che
il diploma in quel tipo di scuola
mi tornasse più utile in un futuro.
Conscio di questo,
decisi di rincarare la dose
frequentando un'università
come quella di Economia
non perché mi piacesse veramente,
ma perché pensavo mi lasciasse,
avete presente quell'ampio ventaglio
di possibilità future.
Già mi vedevo lavorare in banca,
e o saltavo lezione
per andare ad arrampicare,
o quelle poche volte che mi presentavo,
arrivavo con il mio zaino,
carico di attrezzatura,
corda e tutto il resto,
pronto per scappare,
e forse due fogli con cui
prendere appunti.
Sapete, la scuola, l'università,
l'istruzione
sono dei veri e propri doni
che la società ci dà
per diventare uomini liberi,
persone migliori,
capaci di ragionare con la propria testa.
Io questa cosa purtroppo l'ho scoperta
quando forse era un po' troppo tardi,
ma sapete come sono diventato
comunque un uomo libero,
una persona migliore?
Paradossalmente attraverso
la cosa più irrazionale
e quindi più comunemente inutile,
seguendo tutto il ragionamento.
Ho seguito le mie passioni.
Io di lavoro faccio il fotografo
e il film maker outdoor.
Cosa significa?
Letteralmente fotografo
persone e atleti là fuori,
per lo più in montagna.
Il mio non è un lavoro
propriamente convenzionale,
come potete vedere,
perché mi piace stare appeso
con la mia corda
a grandi altezze e forti esposizioni.
Il presupposto per essere un fotografo
e film maker outdoor è sapersi muovere
nell'ambiente in cui si va a fotografare,
ovvero saper raggiungere un luogo
il più delle volte è molto più importante
della fotografia stessa.
La fotografia e l'arrampicata
mi hanno accompagnato
ormai negli ultimi
dieci anni della mia vita.
Prima la fotografia,
attraverso un regalo che mio padre
mi fece per avere dei ricordi.
Poi è arrivata subito dopo l'arrampicata
in una torrida giornata d'estate,
ancora me lo ricordo,
su una parete che brulicava di scorpioni.
Un'esperienza che sconsiglierei
a chiunque di avere.
Eppure quel giorno,
nonostante avessi paura e facessi fatica,
mi sentivo libero, quasi invincibile.
E da quel giorno è ovvio
che non ho più smesso.
La fotografia e l'arrampicata
sono nate per caso
e si sono unite in maniera inscindibile,
sempre per caso.
Tanto che se dovessi
scegliere l'una o l'altra,
probabilmente rinuncerei ad entrambe.
La fotografia per me,
e l'arrampicata soprattutto,
l'arrampicata è stata un modo
per scoprire la montagna,
in tutte le sue sfaccettature,
per capire, per vederla
nel suo ciclo delle stagioni,
nel suo modo di evolversi.
L'unica costante rimaneva
la macchina fotografica nel mio zaino.
Partivo da casa verso qualsiasi luogo
che invece mi facesse sentire a casa.
Fosse una falesia in Spagna,
o le pareti delle gole del Verdon,
una cresta sul mone Bianco,
o la prima highline al mondo
su The Old Man of Stone, in Scozia,
sull'isola di Skye.
Oggi, con questa faccia stanca,
mi rivedo un po' come Yvon Chouinard,
nel mio piccolo mi vedo anch'io
un conquistatore dell'inutile,
ricerco i momenti nel presente
come attimi più importanti nella mia vita,
ricerco il mio inutile per,
citando Messner, mai me ne voglia,
"non sentirmi morire dentro."
La montagna mi ha insegnato
tantissime cose:
mi ha insegnato l'importanza
di essere invisibile,
l'importanza di non lasciare
nessuna traccia
se non l'impronta dei miei passi.
La montagna stava
e sta tuttora lì immobile,
io mi muovo grato su di essa.
Sapete, la natura, nel momento
in cui ti apre le braccia,
non ti chiede nemmeno di rispettarla,
però nel momento in cui riesci
ad ascoltarla in silenzio,
sviluppi una sensibilità tutta nuova,
una responsabilità prima verso te stesso,
e poi riesci a restituirgliela.
La cosa che mi piace di più delle montagne
è che riesco a vederle
come la dimensione di collegamento
tra il finito e l'infinito,
cioè la cima delle montagne è il punto
più alto che possiamo raggiungere
per arrivare quasi a toccare, a vedere,
una realtà che non è
nemmeno più la nostra,
dove non esiste nemmeno più
il valore del tempo.
La fotografia mi ha insegnato
tante altre cose.
Ho iniziato a fotografare
per avere dei ricordi,
e poi si è evoluta in un modo
in cui mi chiedeva di fotografare
solamente quello che credevo più bello.
Fa sorridere, perché dicono che non esista
niente di più inutile dell'arte,
eppure dicono anche che in natura
non esista nulla di inutile,
nemmeno l'inutilità stessa.
Oggi fotografo per vivere
e raccontare storie,
perché è di storie
che siamo fatti tutti noi.
Insieme, l'arrampicata e la fotografia
mi hanno insegnato il valore intrinseco
dell'utilità dell'inutile.
Oggi, se sono qua,
non è per dirvi cosa
dovete o dovreste fare.
Vorrei lasciarvi un messaggio
che, però, sia la mia parte più sincera.
Cerchiamo il nostro inutile,
cerchiamo quella cosa che
ci faccia sentire vivi,
perché l'inutile è l'unico metro
che abbiamo
per misurare il nostro tempo
e la nostra felicità.
Qualunque esso sia.
Nel momento in cui avremo trovato
il nostro inutile,
e saremo in grado di condividerlo,
penso veramente che potremo essere felici.
È in quel momento che il nostro inutile
diventerà utile,
perché le azioni fini a se stesse
sono l'unico modo che abbiamo,
non solo per elevarci spiritualmente
come individui,
ma anche per una crescita civile
e culturale collettiva di tutti noi.
Quindi la domanda è:
siete pronti a cominciare a conquistare
il vostro inutile?
Grazie.
(Applausi)
Grazie Trento.